die US Airways Ramstein in der Pfalz vor
genau 35 Jahren es ist Flugtag an die
350.000 Menschen sind zu Besuch und
sehen das Spektakel am Himmel
Marc David junges damals vier Jahre alt
und mit seinen Eltern in Ramstein er
selbst kann sich kaum erinnern nur dass
er Eis gegessen hat was dann passiert
ist wurde ihm später erzählt es ist
zunächst ein fröhlicher Tag
auf dem Boden gespielt meine Mutter saß
auf einem
Campinghocker und hat sich das eigenes
angeschaut
auch der Sohn von Marliese und Alfred
Witt ist auf der erbase ohne Eltern
fliegen ist der Traum des 16-Jährigen
Mario er hat dafür gelebt er wollte
Pilot werden und wollte dann eben auch
nach Ramstein unbedingt
als Höhepunkt des flugtags will eine
italienische Fliegerstaffel der
schönstes Kunststück zeigen das
durchstoßende Herz
dabei kommt es zur Katastrophe
Mark David Jungs Mutter zieht ihren
Jungen mit bloßen Händen aus dem Inferno
aufgrund der fallenden
hunderte Menschen sind schwer verletzt
verbrannt von Trümmern getroffen manche
niedergetrampelt ihre Versorgung gelingt
nicht gut die us-soldatenräumen sofort
des Gelände eine rettungstaktik wie im
Krieg so werden schwerst verletzte
unversorgt abtransportiert einer der
ersten deutschen Notärzte vor Ort
erinnert sich
verletzt hatten wo wir begonnen hatten
Infusionen zu legen die wurden uns aus
den Händen gerissen aber ohne Rücksicht
auf diese Infusion die sich dabei gelöst
haben und wurden auf den nächsten
Pritschenwagen
geworfen das war eine sehr chaotische
Stimmung weil es vor Ort keinerlei
Einsatzleitung gab oder keine Planung
auch stattgefunden hatte vor Jahren
Ausnahmezustand aber diese Soldaten und
auch bei denen gab es keine Planung es
fehlt ein leidender Notarzt der den
Einsatz hätte koordinieren können die
Verletzten werden planlos in schnell
überfüllte Krankenhäuser gebracht und
bleiben teilweise Stunden sich selbst
überlassen
auch die Toten werden sehr schnell
weggefahren nach dem Unglück um 15:44
sind sie laut Augenzeugen schon um 18
Uhr abtransportiert worden
wer überlebt hat wer nicht ist tagelang
nicht klar von Mario Witt fehlt jede
Spur
eine Minute
natürlich
der Name des 16-Jährigen findet sich auf
keiner Liste die Eltern hoffen er könnte
in die USA ausgeflogen worden sein doch
wo sie auch anrufen sie bleiben im
Ungewissen das waren die sechs
schlimmsten Tage meines Lebens man hat
immer wieder gesagt mario ist nicht hier
bitte da waren ja 30 Tote am Anfang
mario ist hier nicht bei den Toten dabei
man ist in einem Wechselbad der Gefühle
weil es einfach man hat immer noch
Hoffnung in einer Minute und eine Minute
später schon wieder eine kann doch nicht
sein
erst nach sechs Tagen wird Mario
identifiziert anhand seines
Schlüsselbundes er starb auf der er weiß
wie er zu Tode kam erfahren die Eltern
damals nicht und sie dürfen ihn nicht
mehr sehen
lange Jahre werden sie zweifeln ob ihr
Sohn wirklich tot ist
der vierjährige mag David jung und seine
Mutter werden im Chaos nach dem Unglück
voneinander getrennt und dann kam sie
den unterschiedlichen Kliniken ich nach
Mannheim meine Mutter nach Aachen und da
waren wir drei Monate fest getrennt und
sie wusste nicht ob ich am Leben war ob
mein Vater am Leben war
sein Vater hat nicht überlebt Mark David
bleibt monatelang in der Klinik in den
kommenden Jahren wird er viel operiert
seine Mutter steht im immer zur Seite
ich habe eine zum Glück gute Kindheit
gehabt ich konnte normal in Kindergarten
noch mal in die Schule gehen habe
Freunde gehabt das ist vielleicht nicht
selbstverständlich ja
am Tag nach der Katastrophe werden
kunstflugvorführungen in Deutschland
vorerst verboten das Unglück kostet über
70 Menschen das Leben über tausend
werden verletzt ungezählt viele
traumatisiert die Verantwortung dafür
wird nie wirklich geklärt eine
trainationale Untersuchungskommission
stellt menschliches Versagen des
italienischen solopiloten fest
Versäumnisse bei Sicherheitsmaßnahmen
für das Publikum werden nicht
eingestanden man hätte das auf jeden
Fall verhindern können
und das wie gesagt dann keine dazu steht
dass es eben nicht verhindert wurde dass
ärgert mich auch heute noch die hatten
noch keine 100 Meter noch unter 100
Meter Abstand und dann war es
vorprogrammiert wenn was passiert das
ist dann zu einer Katastrophe kommt
die Entschädigung der Opfer fällt gering
aus es gibt nur Geld für Sachschäden
Behandlungskosten und körperliche
Schmerzen seelisches Leid wird kaum
entschädigt eine Sammelklage wegen
psychischer Spätfolgen scheitert
Alfred und Marliese wird erkranken beide
psychosomatisch er muss sogar seinen
Beruf aufgeben und umschulen
es war so dass wir da so gut wie gar
keine wirkliche Hilfe bekommen haben das
ist erst geschehen als wunderbare
Menschen diese Rammstein nachsorgegruppe
gegründet haben erst da ist mir klar
geworden mit so einem Schicksal kann man
nicht im stillen Kämmerlein fertig
werden absolut nicht
die nachsorgegruppe wird ehrenamtlich
gegründet von einer Therapeutin einem
Arzt und einem Seelsorger für alle
Überlebenden und Hinterbliebenen sowie
die Rettungskräfte von Rammstein
gemeinsam begehen sie die Jahrestage und
tauschen sich aus sie wollen von den
anderen hören wir haben sie es erlebt
sie haben das Gefühl sie sind nicht
alleine
sie teilen das was sie erlebt haben
miteinander und dann entwickeln sich
auch spezifische Fragen es entwickeln
sich die Fragen der Wahrheit es
entwickelt sich die Fragen wie ist denn
da das Unglück gewesen können wir noch
mal jemanden sprechen
das Konzept ist damals neu und hilft den
traumatisierten und Trauernden
in der Gruppe fahren Sie nach Italien um
sich die Wracks der abgestürzten Flieger
anzusehen zusammen können sie besser
begreifen und einordnen was ihnen
passiert ist sie bilden eine
Schicksalsgemeinschaft
wir haben dort gelernt miteinander zu
weinen aber auch wieder miteinander zu
lachen
beides gehört zum Leben
ist einfach lebenswichtig gewesen diese
Gruppe
die nachsorgegruppe besteht bis heute
und macht auf die sozialen und
psychischen Spätschäden von Katastrophen
aufmerksam
was erst jetzt nach Ramstein
eingestanden entstanden ist ist die
Definition des psychischen Traumas also
neben den körperlichen Verletzungen es
kommt ja aus der Chirurgie ein Trauma
hier aber das ist dauerhafte Veränderung
im Gehirn gibt was lebenslänglich
bleiben wird
Mark David jung ist froh dass er an
keinen psychischen vollgestörungen
leidet er ist Softwareentwickler
geworden über 30 Operationen hat er
hinter sich und gelernt zu akzeptieren
was nicht zu verändern ist seine
Strategie
denke ich mal der Blick nach vorne um
einfach die Zukunft zu sehen
heute ist er 39 und dankbar dafür am
Leben zu sein er ist zuversichtlich
gestimmt und möchte das gern weitergeben
vor kurzem hat er geheiratet
ich wünsche mir dass ich meinen Leben so
leben kann wie ich bisher tue mit meiner
Frau zusammen mit Nachwuchs irgendwann
und dass ich mein Leben weiterhin so
positiv gestalten kann wie es bisher tue
35 Jahre ist die Katastrophe von
Rammstein nun her vergessen ist sie
nicht
Marliese und Alfred Witt reden fast
jeden Tag über ihren verstorbenen Sohn
sie hat sich zur Trauerbegleiterin für
andere ausbilden lassen
und das ist für mich bis heute
Lebensaufgabe anderen Menschen Mut zu
machen zum Leben das denke ich ist auch
ein Auftrag von Mario
der Vater wünscht sich mehr Akzeptanz
für seine anhaltende Trauer
dass ich da nicht als Außenseiter stehe
sondern als normale Person die ein Kind
verloren hat und das Recht hat
ja sie trauern
das Unglück von Rammstein die
Betroffenen begleitet es ihr Leben lang